[Music]
you may have noticed your paycheck is
struggling to keep up with rising costs
the prices you pay for everyday items
were nearly five and a half percent
higher in july than a year ago we're now
seeing the biggest increases in 13 years
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger is here and joining us at
the table joe good morning good morning
good to see you so let's talk about
what's driving this rise in inflation
and do you see it slowing down well
what's driving it is first of all a
comparison to a year ago when the
economy was not fully opened up and so
obviously the comparison looks terrible
as you said 5.4 percent higher but
beyond that because that's a temporary
situation we still have supply chain
issues that are really clogging up the
system and these bottlenecks do create
price pressures and of course we
consumers we are driving inflation we've
been pent up sitting on more than two
trillion dollars of excess savings we
want to spend and that consumer demand
and spending is pushing prices up so
where are people seeing the biggest
price increases well it's unfortunately
in the things that you touch every
single day right so you know right it's
food and energy and economists always
like to say oh no let's look at the core
inflation rate because that takes out
food and energy but food and energy are
what we actually experience so energy
prices anyone who's driven up 40 from a
year ago but let's look back two years
to 2019 even when we look back two years
a 13 in increa 13 increase in your
energy prices and then on top of that a
15
increase in the grocery store bills
especially for the proteins right so
poultry and meat and fish and eggs and
then an 8.1 percent increase in dining
out so these things put together make
people nuts and some of it is going to
be temporary but the big question is
whether it's going to last longer than
economists believe a million jobs added
uh in july how does that then affect an
infect or affect would be the word most
people use inflation
well it's interesting because in the
last jobs report it was a very robust
report okay and wages were up pretty
significantly year over year but the
thing is because prices are up so much
it eats into those increases that we've
seen in our paychecks in fact if you
look at the inflation adjusted
effect on wages people are down by 1.2
percent from a year ago and that's why
people are complaining that like oh my
god i don't feel like i can get ahead
so can the government do something to
curb inflation without also slowing down
the economy so this is the job of the
federal reserve and in econo speak it's
called the dual mandate it means they've
got two big jobs one job is to foster
enough economic growth to get these more
than eight million people back on the
job right so that's really important but
they've got to keep their eyes on prices
because with inflation it can really be
detrimental over the long term federal
reserve chair jerome powell has said
that the central bank is willing to let
inflation run a bit hotter than it
normally would because of this strange
situation so they'll probably act but
it's not now all right and i shall
pursue my dual mandate to both interview
you and hit this commercial break
thank you i appreciate it